-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for tuning in.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, today,
the C.E.O. of Pfizer said that
its vaccine for the Omicron
variant will be ready in March.
So get ready for the craziest
St. Patrick's Day
in the history of the world.
[ Irish accent ] Omicron.
[ Normal voice ] Pretty soon,
the C.E.O. of Pfizer
is going to be on
Instagram Live like,
"New vaccine just dropped.
Sound off in the comments!
What?!"
It feels like this
March Madness,
we'll be filling out brackets
to predict
which of the 68 variants
become the dominant strain.
Listen to this.
According to the CDC,
only 1 in 10 adults in the U.S.
eat enough
fruits and vegetables.
Good timing on this news, CDC.
It sort of feels like
their version of
"Hey, what's over there?"
"There's a bird.
Look, there's a bird."
Yep, the CDC says adults
should eat 2 to 3 cups
of vegetables a day.
Wait. Now they're saying 4 to 5.
No, wait.
No, now they're saying only 1.
Basically, barely 1 or 2.
You're fine with 1.
Yeah, we'll figure it out.
I heard that Tesla's
self-driving program
now offers three different modes
that control behaviors,
like rolling stops,
running yellow lights,
and how close you are
to follow other drivers.
And they have three modes.
They're called Chill, Average,
and Assertive.
And this is fun.
You can also hit Mood Swing and
try all three at random.
And I also heard that some
Honda and Acura models
have been hit with a bug
that resets their clocks
20 years in the past.
The company
could tell something was up
when drivers seemed happy.
It's crazy.
People were driving along.
Then, all of a sudden,
the radio would only play
the Goo Goo Dolls.
Yeah. Get this.
I saw that nearly 15,000 pounds
of Walmart beef sticks
have been recalled
because they forgot to label
a potential allergen.
Yep, Walmart beef sticks
must now have a label
that says "Warning -- you're
eating Walmart beef sticks."
Oh.
-Oh. Oh, okay.
-Yeah.
Apparently, a supermarket chain
in the U.K. is getting rid of
the "use by" dates on its milk
and encouraging customers
to use the sniff test.
Yep, here's how it works
in every house.
You grab a carton
and immediately go,
"Honey, does
this smell bad to you?"
And, finally, a farmer in Turkey
is having his cows
wear V.R. goggles
that simulate green pastures
so that
they'll be less anxious.
Take a look at this.
It's real.
Yeah, the cow doesn't make
any more milk,
but it is really good at
the new game "Beef Saber."
We have a great show, everybody.
Give it up for The Roots!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much, everybody.
Some sad news last night.
We heard that our friend
Bob Saget passed away.
He was a great guest
on our show.
Funny, funny, funny guy
and one of the nicest people
you could ever meet.
Our thoughts go out
to his family.
We're going to miss you, Bob.
[ Applause ]